so about a week ago we received numerous
photos of Tom Holland on the set of
spider-man far from home and following
up with that we have now received our
first leaked video of Tom Holland
filming spider-man far from home before
we get started be sure to subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
spider-man far from home and Avengers 4
so here is the quick little video taken
by a fan
[Music]
as you can see there's not much here
it's not very long but there are a few
things you can notice for starters he's
in street clothes and he has his
backpack with him this may mean that he
could be at school and that he just
jumped on top of the school roof or he
swung into it you can see that in this
video he's clearly jumping down from
something now the title is called far
from home and Marvel President Kevin
Feige came out and stated that he's on
vacation so it's probably not his school
building it's probably just a random
building in London where he jumps or
swings on top of just to get away so he
either swung on top of this building or
just leapt from another building or even
leap from the ground but one thing that
is very peculiar here is that it looks
like he's morning looks like he's
weeping like he's very sad he's putting
his head in his hands almost like he
just lost somebody and he's still
getting over it any guess on who that
could be
we're not really sure what's going to
happen in Avengers floor and who all is
going to make it out alive we're not but
if he is mourning the death of somebody
my guess is it's Tony Stark but in the
middle of his morning it looks like he
gets interrupted maybe he hears
something because he turns and he looks
in the distance but kind of seems like
he can't see what it is now this could
be almost anything it could be pepper
and an Iron Man suit it could be some
sort of AI that Tony created it could be
a bad guy it could very well be Mysterio
showing up or it could be vulture at
this point with just such little footage
there's really no way to tell but again
I think the main thing to notice here is
that he's mourning he said he's weeping
on top of this rooftop
he sat enough to where wherever he is he
has to jump and get away so he can take
some time out just to be sad so does
this tell us that Tony Stark dies in
Avengers 4 in a supposed plot leak that
we received about two weeks ago that
went crazy around the internet it says
that Tony dies and that's kind of the
start of the movie is that spider-man is
mourning so it seems like this is all
sort of lining up together but until we
receive more information about Avengers
4 and about spider-man far from home all
we can really do
is speculate so there it is there is the
first leaked footage we have from
spider-man far from home what do you all
think do you also think that it looks
like he is mourning and if you do do you
think it's because Tony Stark has died
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and be sure to like this
video if you enjoyed it and don't forget
to subscribe to my channel so you can
stay up to date with spider-man fire
from home Avengers for all things Marvel
DC and superhero thank you so much for
watching woof woof
[Music]
you